practiquemos a dibujar las
conformaciones de sillas una forma es
dibujando dos líneas paralelas un poco
desalineadas aquí tenemos una y aquí
tenemos otra están paralelas pero
desalineadas después dibujamos una línea
punteada por arriba y una línea punteada
por abajo
ahora dibujemos otro par de líneas
paralelas la primera línea inicia en
este punto y termina en la línea
punteada de abajo así que la segunda
línea debe quedar paralela a ésta
empezamos en este punto y ahora nos
vamos hacia la línea punteada de arriba
finalmente solo conectamos los puntos
este punto con este y este punto con
este vamos a revisar lo que dibujamos
este enlace es paralelo a este enlace
que fue como empezamos después dibujamos
este par de líneas y finalmente
dibujamos estas líneas paralelas
entonces este es nuestro esqueleto de
carbonos ahora como en este caso estamos
hablando del hexa no sólo tenemos
hidrógenos entonces primero pongamos los
hidrógenos en la posición axial imaginen
que es
es el planeta tierra y este es su eje
que lo tenemos arriba y abajo entonces
los hidrógenos axiales sólo pueden estar
hacia arriba o hacia abajo para
dibujarlos empecemos con este carbono
que es nuestro carbono 1 aquí tenemos un
hidrógeno axial que va hacia arriba
después en el carbono 2 tenemos un
hidrógeno axial hacia abajo en el
carbono 3 tenemos un hidrógeno axial
hacia arriba en el carbono 4 el
hidrógeno axial hacia abajo en el
carbono 5 lo tenemos hacia arriba y en
el carbono 6 se encuentra hacia abajo
observen que los hidrógenos están
alternados iniciamos con el carbono 1 y
el hidrógeno axial está hacia arriba
pongamos los hidrógenos axiales en
nuestro dibujo
aquí tenemos el carbono 1 y vamos a
dibujar una línea hacia arriba aquí
tenemos el hidrógeno después avanzamos
al carbono 2 y dibujamos una línea hacia
abajo con un hidrógeno en el carbono 3
dibujamos una línea hacia arriba con su
hidrógeno en el carbono 4 dibujamos una
línea hacia abajo con un hidrógeno en el
carbono 5 dibujamos una línea hacia
arriba y un hidrógeno
finalmente en el carbono 6 el hidrógeno
axial está hacia abajo ahora veamos los
hidrógenos ecuatoriales si empezamos en
el carbono 1
este es el hidrógeno ecuatorial y en el
carbono 2 sería este hidrógeno se les
llama ecuatoriales porque su posición se
parece a la línea ecuatorial del planeta
este es el ecuador entonces este tipo de
hidrógenos se encuentra hacia los lados
y también están alternados en el carbono
1 este hidrógeno ecuatorial se encuentra
hacia abajo respecto al plano y en el
carbono 2
este hidrógeno ecuatorial se encuentra
hacia arriba entonces empezamos hacia
abajo después arriba y en el carbono 3
se encuentra hacia abajo en el carbono 4
se encuentra hacia arriba en el carbono
5 se encuentra hacia abajo y en el
carbono 6 se encuentra hacia arriba
imaginen que todos estos hidrógenos se
encuentran en el ecuador del anillo
entonces dibujemos estos hidrógenos en
nuestra conformación empecemos con el
carbono 1 y el hidrógeno ecuatorial está
hacia abajo después vamos hacia arriba
en el carbono 2 y luego simplemente
alternamos en el carbono 3 el hidrógeno
ecuatorial va hacia abajo en el carbono
4 el hidrógeno ecuatorial queda hacia
arriba en el carbono 5 nos queda hacia
abajo y en el carbono 6 va hacia arriba
muchas veces se confunden con los
hidrógenos ecuatoriales pero no es tan
complicado simplemente usen de guía las
líneas paralelas que dibujamos al inicio
es decir empezamos con las líneas
paralelas de color amarillo entonces
podemos dibujar esta línea que es
paralela a esta y también podemos
basarnos en las líneas rojas que nos dan
la guía para estos grupos y finalmente
las líneas de color azul nos guían para
dibujar
líneas paralelas
otra forma para dibujarlas sería
siguiendo esta línea de la derecha y si
resaltamos todos los enlaces a los que
se conecta esta figura les resulta
familiar la vimos anteriormente en las
conformaciones del etano representa la
proyección de caballete en la
conformación alternada
la dibujaré de este lado para que la
vean mejor esta es la conformación
alternada del etano y puede ayudarnos a
dibujar los enlaces ecuatoriales en la
conformación de silla entonces ustedes
pueden usar el método que quieran hay
muchas formas de dibujar una
conformación de silla pero al final solo
necesitan tomarse su tiempo y practicar
mucho echemos un vistazo a otra
conformación de silla
sigamos practicando para dibujar con
formaciones de silla empezaremos de la
misma forma que en el ejercicio anterior
dibujemos las líneas paralelas pero
ahora del lado contrario después
dibujamos las líneas punteadas una que
pasa por arriba recuerde las líneas
punteadas solo son una guía no forman
parte de la conformación y tenemos otra
por abajo que pasa por este punto
ahora vamos a dibujar una línea
inclinada que va desde este punto de
arriba hasta la línea punteada de abajo
y después dibujamos una línea que va
desde abajo hacia arriba
finalmente conectemos los puntos este
punto se conecta con este y este punto
se conecta con éste siempre asegúrense
de que todas las líneas sean paralelas
al final deben de quedar tres pares de
líneas paralelas y el primero que
dibujamos fue esta línea con esta
después dibujamos esta línea que es
paralela a esta y finalmente dibujamos
esta línea que debe quedar paralela a
esta entonces siempre verifiquen que
haya tres pares de líneas paralelas en
su esqueleto de carbonos ahora aquí
tenemos nuestro carbono 1 que en otro
vídeo les explicaré por qué dibujemos
los grupos axiales en el carbono 1
podemos ver que empezamos con un grupo
axial hacia abajo así que pondremos un
hidrógeno esto es lo contrario a lo que
vimos en la otra conformación de silla
donde empezábamos con el grupo axial
hacia arriba pero aquí empezamos hacia
abajo y ponemos nuestro hidrógeno
después nos movemos al carbono 2 y aquí
tenemos el grupo axial hacia arriba que
es un hidrógeno entonces en el carbono 2
vamos hacia arriba
en el carbono 3 que sería este podemos
ver que el grupo axial queda hacia abajo
entonces en el carbono 3 vamos hacia
abajo y observen que simplemente
alternamos así que en el carbono 4 vamos
hacia arriba vamos a dibujarlo en el
carbono 5 vamos hacia abajo
y finalmente en el carbono 6 nos queda
hacia arriba y tenemos un hidrógeno
ahora dibujemos los grupos ecuatoriales
observen que este grupo ecuatorial es
paralelo a esta línea que a su vez es
paralela a esta y por lo tanto también
tenemos esta línea paralela entonces en
el carbono 1 tenemos un grupo ecuatorial
que está hacia arriba respecto al plano
entonces tenemos el grupo ecuatorial
hacia arriba con un hidrógeno después en
el carbono 2 ya teníamos un hidrógeno
axial hacia arriba por lo tanto el grupo
ecuatorial debe de ir hacia abajo
entonces hacia abajo y esta línea debe
ser paralela a las líneas de color rojo
y no olvidemos el hidrógeno en el
carbono 3 nos queda ecuatorial hacia
arriba observen que esta línea es
paralela a las líneas azules entonces en
el carbono 3 tenemos una línea
historial hacia arriba con un hidrógeno
y nuevamente alternamos empezamos con
ecuatorial arriba después ecuatorial
abajo y nos faltó poner el hidrógeno
después ecuatorial arriba y luego
tenemos ecuatorial hacia abajo entonces
en el carbono 4 tenemos el hidrógeno
ecuatorial hacia abajo en el carbono 5
tenemos un hidrógeno ecuatorial hacia
arriba y está línea debe ser paralela a
las líneas en rojo así es más fácil que
no se confunda vamos a dibujarlo por
aquí y finalmente en el carbono 6
tenemos un hidrógeno ecuatorial hacia
abajo paralelo a las líneas azules vamos
a dibujarlo por acá ecuatorial hacia
abajo entonces se necesita mucha
práctica sigan practicando para que
puedan dibujar los dos tipos de
conformación este sillas